SPEAKER 1: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE]
Google Developer Advocate.
I'm joined here today by Dave
Rensin, Director of Customer
Reliability Engineering.
Now, Dave, CREs are renowned
for being able to take care of,
or at least expect, pretty
much any contingency, you know.
But there are certain
laws of nature
that you can take
for granted, right?
DAVE RENSIN: Like?
SPEAKER 1: Lightning
never strikes twice.
DAVE RENSIN: As far as
lightning never striking twice,
that was clearly invented
by someone who never worked
in a data center in Belgium.
We had one that actually
got hit by lightning
four times within a few minutes.
SPEAKER 1: So avoid
taking shelter
in data centers
in Belgium, yeah?
DAVE RENSIN: Yeah,
or maybe God just
doesn't like cloud data
centers in Belgium.
SPEAKER 1: I think we'll
move on from there.
Tell me, Dave, where can people
find more stories like this?
DAVE RENSIN: Well, if you're
going to be at Google Next,
you should stop by
the 5th Nine Lounge,
a dedicated space where you can
meet Google senior SREs, CREs,
Customer DevOps people, and
learn about all the wacky,
wild, and, well,
downright weird stuff we
have to deal with day to day.
SPEAKER 1: We look forward
to seeing you there.